In order to be falsely
accused I would need accusers.
I turned to my intern, Josh,
and his girlfriend, Tina.
So this is the police blotter
for the city of Burbank.
Now pick a crime on here,
any crime at all,
and then accuse me of it.
I don't want you to back down
no matter what,
no matter what the police say,
certainly no matter what I say.
Just point the finger of blame
at me, please,
and keep it pointed.
Okay.
Yeah, no problem.
Okay, good.
See, look here.
Someone's been stealing avocados
from this woman's tree.
Like, that's perfect.
What you doing?
Oh, you're getting started.
- You know what to do?
- I think Tina's got it.
(Forrest)
But very quickly, I began
to suspect I'd left this task
to the wrong people.
Josh and Tina seemed to be
putting off their accusation
in favor of all other
manner of business.
While on an outing
to buy headphones
from a store
called craigslist,
Tina ran out of gas.
You get this at the gas station,
fill it up with gas.
Well, if I'm going
to the gas station,
- I'm just gonna fill it up.
- Sure.
- Yes, you can hold on to that.
- Have a good day.
I hope you weren't doing
anything really important.
To be honest, I was not,
but this is still
an inconvenience.
(Forrest)
Josh, in an effort to make up
for this frustrating time suck,
offered to have
my glasses fixed...
Like, this side is closer
to my face than this side.
(Forrest)
An errand
which I did appreciate,
as they'd been crooked
ever since I was shot in them.
- Here you go.
- Thank you very much.
I felt useless in the meantime,
a feeling Tina tried to soothe
by having me sign some responses
to our fan mail.
I guess they'd get a big kick
out of seeing my name
signed on there, huh?
(Forrest)
I began to suspect my
coconspirators had completely
forgotten their assignment.
Great.
And that's just your whole name.
All right.
(Forrest)
I couldn't have
been more wrong.
The police are here
for you.
[sighs]
At last.
- Are you Forrest MacNeil?
- Yes, I am.
But, officers, I'm sorry to say
you've got the wrong man.
I don't even like avocados.
You see, they upset my stomach.
Great. You're under arrest
for arson, attempted murder...
- What? No, no, no.
- And destruction of property.
What are you talking about?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, hey.
You have the right
to remain silent.
Oh, no, no.
Hey, Dad, call my lawyer, okay?
Forr--
Who's your lawyer?
- Call a really good lawyer.
- A realty lawyer?
If you cannot afford
an attorney,
one will be appointed for you.
Oh, Forrest.
(Forrest)
My lawyer, Daisy,
rushed to the police station.
What took you so long?
I couldn't find my shoes.
Well, this is ridiculous.
I mean, they can't possibly have
any kind of case against me.
Well, I normally would
tell you not to worry, Forrest,
but I think you should worry.
How could it be bad? There's
no way for this to be bad.
(Forrest)
To my shock and horror,
I had been charged with
the incredibly serious crime
of burning down
a sorority house
at the University
of Southern California.
They found
your fingerprints
all over this container used
to pour gas on the house.
Well, that ought to do it.
They found eyeglasses
that match your prints
and your prescription.
- Here you go.
- Thank you very much.
I appreciate it.
Think about it for a second.
How would I have driven home
from there without my glasses?
Well, you might have
a backup pair.
- I do have a backup pair.
- Oh, my God.
And finally, a whole series
of hand-signed hate letters.
"Put a jacket on, whores."
That's my signature.
"Life--it's literally
all you have.
"And you're a bunch
of stuck-up sluts.
Signed, Forrest MacNeil."
I guess
they'd get a big kick
out of seeing my name
signed on there, huh?
(Forrest)
Apparently, Josh and Tina
had not felt it adequate
to simply point the finger at me
for a minor crime.
This was supposed
to be stolen avocados.